okay so we established the
cross-dressing thing we've established
the pro wrestling thing yeah yeah
metal singing how did that come from so
um so when i moved to hong kong i
started learning cantonese because
that's the language i speak there and so
um one of the strategies i had for
learning languages was i would get
music in that language which i'm sure
you guys have probably gone through here
with japanese yeah java not connor from
the look on his face but
you get music that you like in the
language yeah so i started listening to
uh cantonese pop songs
most of the music is pop there's very
little anything else in hong kong right
so i missed these pop songs um and my
favorite numbers are metalhead
from way back actually my favorite songs
full stop were always like metal covers
of pop songs
right right so like you know metal
covers of like last friday night and
yeah [ __ ] your face and things like that
yeah because they're hilarious right
because you're so used to hearing lady
gaga with you know
carrying my pocket and then you hear
yeah robot bow
oh that's so funny right i think it's
fantastic
because it takes what you're used to and
it subverts it yeah yeah
that's the thing of beauty so when i
started listening to these candies pop
songs i was like these are really catchy
songs
who's done the metal covers turns out no
one had right and i was like well
someone should do that
free real estate isn't three years later
um i uh it was after the financial
crisis everything had been wiped out i'm
like what am i gonna do
i was uh going through like one of those
exercises where you figure out your
career and what you're gonna do
like what are you passionate about and
i'm like heavy metal and destroying
things
so i'm like okay i want to be a metal
singer and i was like okay
specifically i want to sing metal covers
of cantonese pop songs because i think
they'll sound
awesome no one else has done it i'm
going to goddamn do it yeah
wow so i did and then what i said was
okay so i've already got this
fan base organized with the wrestling
i'm gonna do this metal project
as ladybeard and i'm gonna bring that
fan base over and then i'm gonna try and
do this amazing interesting thing of
working
the pro wrestling world and the heavy
metal world together
so the story lines are interlocked and
they flow back and forth between them
you're like 15 years too early to
tick-tock yeah
i feel like those heavy metal covers
would blow up on ticks yeah exactly
hearing you talk about the financial
crisis like this devastating thing is so
bizarre because i was just so young
i'm pretty [ __ ] myself from watching
finding nemo the thought of it having an
impact
yeah i mean what it was 2008 right yeah
i was 14.
i was i was in university i'm 24. oh my
god
holy smoker yeah i mean like you know i
was like i think i was 11 then yeah
because i had heard like from my parents
being like you know like damn the wall
got [ __ ] over this is a big thing
that's going to happen and i'm just like
i'm just trying to get through my degree
right now
i'm still probably eating cocoa pops and
you know picking my nose
but we've got to realize the same kind
of thing has happened now with coconut
19 and
all four of us are very lucky that we
can still sit here and employ absolutely
exactly
a lot of people are now in that position
that i was in then
and they're going oh god what am i gonna
do yeah yeah so the next generation of
ladybeard is gonna come out
a couple of years from now they'll be
like a little 2.0 with a pink mess
yeah so that's so so yeah that's how it
came to me
when did you move to japan then so then
um so i started doing my metal covers of
candidly pop songs and i started doing
that in hong kong
very good um did a couple of tours to
some nearby places and i said
one of the things that kind of gave me
the confidence to do it in the first
place
because it's sort of when you go full
time as the crossdresser
you can't ever really go back can you
it's kind of it works
or you're screwed right right right so
one of the things that kind of gave me
the confidence to do it was well if i
can't really get anything going on in
hong kong
i know i can always move to japan
because i'm sure they'll love something
like that oh yeah
yeah yeah so i did a tour to japan after
i got myself organized in hong kong
um did japanese songs so i couldn't
speak japanese yet just learnt the songs
phonetically
right oh wow put together a show yeah
came over here
with you know the handful of contacts i
had like three japanese people i knew
right so i put together a show but it
popped because i was doing like covers
of metal covers of like um
what's that girl who sings first love
hikaru shita what's that no that's
that's a wrestler
yeah thank you very much yeah yeah doing
like metal covers of that and so forth
so the audience much they didn't know
who i was right the audience who was at
any of these shows
would see this show they all knew the
songs because they're famous songs yeah
then they'd
they'd be the metal cover of course
they're like this is hilarious
yeah so that too it went incredibly well
right so i'm like okay well clearly i
found the chosen land
the promised land of milk and honey so i
uh yeah so i went back to hong kong and
i'm like all right clearly the mission
now needs to be moved to japan and
japan and i did and here we are oh wow
man do you know what it feels like you
know when you like you put your
headphones in your pocket and it gets
all tangled and you have to like
untangle it
that's literally what we did with your
story right now
it all finally fits together it all
makes sense now it's all finally one
straight line
that i can cop that i can understand
yeah so i came over at the end of 2013
right and then at the start of 2014 my
images
went uh viral on the twitter
um 2015 i was put in this pop group with
these uh
two young singers and uh we did a song
called nippon manju and that blew up on
the youtubes
and um now we're riding high
so okay then like because i would say
like for people who
don't know ladybird for instance i'd say
like i i would say though like
if there's one thing about you that
you've done in your career that's
probably
i would say it's probably the most
well-known would probably be ladybaby of
course yeah right so how did that come
to be
so i was uh it was me and my former
manager
um we're in japan we're only doing stuff
in japan and so forth
and uh so i was on the cover of
metropolis magazine
do you know that magazine i've
definitely heard of that yeah it's it's
a free magazine how can you guys be
foreigners in japan not metropolis
just leave my house see what year it's
been okay
there's a free english magazine like a
street magazine
in tokyo i think in all japan called
metropolis is there i
don't know i've never seen it i've never
seen it i'm definitely afraid of eye
contact with strangers holding things
i'm like don't don't no no
i thought you welshman loved a good
fight
i think i'd be deported very quickly
so there's this magazine well it's a
very popular
magazine amongst every foreigner in
japan except
one two three yeah mainly did you know
about this
yeah right actually did you know about
this teachers
yes there are five foreigners here who
didn't know about it
my friends who work at metropolis
magazine i sincerely apologize for this
negative press
that you are currently receiving on the
trash i'm just saying clearly the
marketing strategy needs to be written
yeah i'm just sure dude that magazine is
everywhere oh it's clear
everywhere where do you get it like like
convenience store
not only could you stop if you go to
tower records or whatnot they've got
that stack of free magazines i don't
think i've been into a tower records in
about a year
you look at the free stack of magazines
i just see potential toilets when you
get to the airport and you're walking
from your plane to immigration there's
always magazines and stuff
i have yeah you're just checking your
phone right i guess
young people
the ceo of a halloween costume company
is uh getting off a plane he's walking
through the airport
and he sees metropolis magazine with me
on it it's me and my pinker white bikini
flexing
all right and he said what the hell is
[Laughter]
[Music]
that
[Laughter]
his ear and he's just like what the [ __ ]
is that
so he takes magazine yeah and he takes
it back to his office
and he's like look at this and his staff
are like yeah that's this ladybeard guy
he's
foreign a dude and he said bring him in
i want to work with him bring him in
wow so we get a contact from this
company and we go in
and he's like i want to work with you
i'm like all right i thought he
was a halloween costume company right i
thought he's going to make like a
line of my bikinis right yeah he's like
i want to work with you but i don't know
how
so we'll be in touch okay like okay
put you in his office yeah we go back to
what we were doing at a month later he
calls us in again
and he's like i'm gonna put you in a pop
group with a pair of uh idols
wow wait wait how did that happen that's
another jump
yeah how did he come up with that i
wasn't there for that okay you know
okay he did that in the privacy your
life just sounds like a roulette wheel
what's going
that's what you get for waking up in
vegas
yeah it's it's just like here's a bunch
of money's like oh i don't even remember
bending on black
um uh anyways okay so so this guy
somehow manages to get you in
this idle group yeah so he had spoke to
some people he knew
and he's i'm gonna put you in a group
and then we did that first song and it
blew up and that was ladybaby
wow so he somehow knew babymetal
wait what baby were they even
established yeah they were
they were very popular at the time
recently after give me chocolate
oh okay yeah yeah so they were very hot
and they were getting spoken about a lot
in japan
but it's like i remember the meeting he
goes
he goes yeah because he's a heavy metal
singer and they're idols
yeah yeah so your baby metal are very
popular at the moment aren't they yeah
this will be just like babymetal but
with ladybeard
ladybeard babymetal
baby that was the meaning i'm like right
really cool
making skills right there he's a smart
man he uh he's from china he came over
to japan
like with no money like 30 years ago or
something and he
made his living like he'd go outside
tokyo domes during the bubble outside
tokyo dome
he would like sell like light sticks or
something when there's sporting events
yeah and he somehow made his business
happen
that is literally how like every
entrepreneur in the 70s started like
that isn't that like every entrepreneur
story from there
it's just like i had no money when
coming to this country in the streets
i sold paper clips and now i own a
multi-million dollar corporation
he did a good job well my dad was rich
gave me a small loan of a million
dollars